Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Chinese action thriller film
called “Kung Fu Jungle”. Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
In the opening scene, a martial arts expert
named Mo walks into the police station. His
face is covered in bruises and cuts that surprise
the officers. When asked what happened, he answers
that he just killed somebody. The officers quickly
call the higher officials and arrest him. It turns
out that Mo was fighting an opponent in the ring
and involuntarily killed him during the match. Mo
knew that what he did was wrong, even though it
was accidental. Hence, he turned himself in.
The scene cuts to three years later. A police
detective named Luk has been called to investigate
a murder crime scene. She is informed that the
person who died was a boxer. At first glance,
a forensic doctor notices broken ribs and limbs,
and blood clots around the eyes. Detective Luk
assumes that the victim must have been tortured
for several days to be that severely injured.
But by the nature of the injuries, the doctor
claims the victim probably got into a fight
with someone very skilled. They also notice a
strange dagger lying on the crime scene.
Somewhere else in the penitentiary, Mo has been
living peacefully for the past three years.
He is often ordered around by a group of inmates.
With his skills, Mo can easily teach them a lesson
but he chooses to avoid any kind of argument.
The news of the death makes it to the television
and catches Mo’s attention. He watches the
broadcast in shock, almost as if he knows
something about the murder. Immediately after, he
runs to the guard and asks him to call detective
Luk. The guard sarcastically questions
him about what else he would like to have.
Mo tries explaining that he knows something about
the recent murder case but is dismissed.
Following that, he picks a fight with a group
of inmates. The leader of the group manages to
hit him on the head with a metal plate but Mo
dodges the second attack and breaks both of his
arms. By now, they are surrounded by policemen
who take them under custody. The prison warden
knows that Mo is not normally a violent person.
Hence, he calls detective Luk and arranges a
meeting between them. Mo finally meets her and
claims that the person who died was his former
friend who he once fought and defeated. By the
nature of the murder, Mo is sure that the killer
is about to go on a killing spree. He isn’t
looking for revenge or money, he wants to fight
with the best kung fu fighters, fair and square.
When asked how he is so sure, Mo fails to provide
a definite answer but claims that if they set
him free, he can help them find the killer.
The detectives assume he is making things up to
get out of prison. As they are about to leave,
Mo recites seven names and declares that
one of them is going to be the next victim.
The names are of the fighters who he has fought
and defeated over the years. Detective Luk doesn’t
believe him but she still asks her junior to
collect information on all seven people.
Then, we see the murderer sharpening
a dagger and writing the name
King Yi on the wall. King Yi is one of the
people that Mo mentioned earlier. He works
in an art museum and is currently working
on a sculpture of a giant human skeleton.
When he is alone in the showroom, the killer
suddenly appears on top of the skull and shows
his face for the first time. He introduces himself
as Yu-Sau and challenges King Yi to a battle.
They fight each other on the top of the
skeleton when King Yi notices that Yu-Sau’s legs
are different lengths. He is wearing a shoe
with a bigger sole to balance himself.
They fight using only their legs but still show
great expertise. Eventually, Yu-Sau traps his
opponent’s leg between his and breaks it. Some
seconds later, he walks away leaving King Yi’s
dead body behind. Back in the police station, the
detective studies the profiles of the seven names
provided by Mo but finds no similarity in them.
All of them live simple lives in different parts
of the city. However, Mo’s past seems interesting
to her. It is revealed that he formed a famous
martial arts club and was a teacher before his
imprisonment. The club has thousands of followers
in the present day. He was also recruited by the
Hong Kong police as a martial art instructor.
As the detectives talk, they get
the news about King Yi’s death.
Detective Luk is shocked that Mo’s prediction
turned out to be true. The very next day, Mo is
let out of the prison temporarily under police
custody. By inspecting the order of killings,
Mo has realized that the killer is targeting his
victims by following a martial arts practice.
First, he killed the boxer who used his hands,
then King Yi who used his legs to fight, so his
next target will probably be someone who wrestles.
Mo knows a wrestler among the remaining six people
but Yu-Sau goes to the man before the police.
When the police arrive at the location,
they see the wrestler's body being thrown from a
window. He also has a similar dagger stabbed to
his arm. Suddenly, Mo looks at the roof of another
building and sees Yu-Sau. His evil smile makes him
realize that he is the murderer. Mo immediately
follows the man while the police do the same. A
few minutes into the chase, Yu-Sau takes a leap to
the top of a neighboring building and disappears,
leaving Mo and the police ashamed that they
couldn’t catch him. Taking the opportunity,
Mo also escapes from police custody.
The next day, he goes to his hometown
Foshan where he meets his wife Sinn Ying. They
are happy to be reunited after three years.
She takes him home and makes him wear a sacred
band on his wrist. It is supposed to make him
fight only for self-defense and protect him from
making the same mistake that got him imprisoned.
At night, Mo finds the killer’s dagger
in one of the boxes with his belongings.
Sinn Ying reveals that a few months ago,
a limping man came to their martial arts
school and asked her to keep the dagger. She
thinks that the town’s historian might know
what the symbol in the dagger means and the
two decide to go to him the next day. Then,
a flashback shows us Yu-Sau with his late wife
who had cancer. She was the only person in the
world who loved and accepted him as he is.
While she was dying, he practiced martial
arts day and night to keep himself from
thinking about her inevitable death.
Back in the present, Mo and Sinn Ying go to the
historian to find out more about the dagger. It is
revealed that the symbol on it is called Eaves
Swallo. During the rule of the Qing dynasty,
it was given to the person who lost in a
martial art fight. The couple is talking
about Yu-Sau when a man nearby overhears
them and claims to know him. He says that
a few years ago Yu-Sau lived with his cancerous
wife in a nearby town. Yu-Sau was born with a
disability that makes one of his legs shorter than
the other. Yet, he was able to master martial art
techniques with hard work and dedication.
Following that, Mo calls detective Luk saying
that he has a lead. The police immediately come
to the town to receive him and make their way to
the killer’s hometown. They arrive at Yu-Sau’s
home but see that he has already moved away.
The landlady claims that she never saw Yu-Sau do
anything other than train. He also used to rub
his face with salt until it bled to thicken
his skin so it could take a longer beating.
Then, the police find writing on the wall
that says he has lost everything in his life,
and now, his only motive is to fight the
best martial artists and be the number
one. That is why he has been killing some of
the best fighters and plans to kill more.
Meanwhile, Yu-Sau goes to his
next target, a former fighter,
and actor. This time, he challenges him to a
duel using swords. After a long and fierce match,
Yu-Sau slits the man’s throat and kills
him. After yet another death, detective Luk
is pressured by the higher officials to solve the
case sooner. She urges Mo to do the same but he
seems to be hiding something from them. Once when
Mo was in prison, he got a letter from Yu-Sau that
vaguely talked about a challenge. Then, Mo didn’t
know what it meant, but now he has realized that
he is the final person Yu-Sau wants to fight.
Detective Luk also starts to suspect Mo and
asks the prison for the CCTV footage of every
meeting he has had with an outsider. At night,
Mo is sitting alone in his room when he remembers
the day before the first murder took place.
Yu-Sau had sent him a letter
asking him to watch the news.
The following day, the police find out about
Yu-Sau’s current address and send a SWAT team to
the house. They search around it but find no one
inside. Just as they are about to leave, they see
that his wife’s ashes are still there which means
he will definitely return to retrieve them.
Detective Luk orders a redeploy and makes
the police stay hidden until Yu-Sau returns
to the house. The next morning, he is seen
approaching the house on a boat. A flashback
shows that his wife was struggling severely
before her death. Yu-Sau couldn’t see her
in such a condition anymore, so he mercy
killed her by strangling her to death.
In the present, the police see him and cautiously
wait for him to come closer so they can all attack
at once. However, Yu-Sau notices guard dogs
around the neighborhood and takes a random turn.
Before anyone knows where he went, he disappears.
Somewhere else, an officer investigating the CCTV
footage from the prison finds out that Yu-Sau
had come to meet Mo while he was in prison.
Detective Luk points her gun at him, believing
that the killings were his and Yu-Sau's plan
to get him out of the prison. Meanwhile, Sinn
Ying has set off to look for Yu-Sau on her own.
Mo swiftly gets hold of the gun from detective
Luk and escapes to pursue Yu-Sau and his wife.
At the same time, Sinn Ying and Yu-Sau meet
inside his house. She hands him his wife’s ashes,
asking him to leave her husband alone. However,
Yu-Sau believes that if he kills her, Mo will be
even stronger. They get into a fight and Sinn
Ying, who is also a trained fighter gives him
tough competition. But eventually, he stabs her in
the arm and runs away. Mo arrives to see his wife
on the floor and calls for help. He notices Yu-Sau
right outside the house and jumps to catch him.
They land on a boat and the container with the
ashes breaks. While struggling, they fall into
the river. Yu-Sau manages to get on top of another
boat and drive away. He eventually crashes to a
boat with detective Luk and the police officers
but disappears soon after. Mo also runs away
after making sure his wife will be saved. He
calls detective Luk and tells her that when
he first got Yu-Sau’s letter, he thought he was
only a fan. Seeing his interest in martial arts,
Mo taught him everything he wanted to know while
he was still in prison. He was unaware that Yu-Sau
will use the knowledge to kill people.
Mo also knew that Yu-Sau was going after Sinn
Ying, and if he had told the police everything
from the beginning, they wouldn’t need his
help. Hence, he kept the secret so he could come
outside the prison and save his wife himself.
Mo knows who Yu-Sau’s next target is. Using the
information, he manages to find Yu-Sau in the
middle of a highway on his way to his target’s
house. Although Mo has a chance to run him over,
he doesn’t do it because he wants to fight
him. Yu-Sau is delighted that his wish is
finally coming true. The two join hands to
respect each other as opponents and start
the battle in the middle of the road. Almost
matching in strength and skills, they are not
able to do any harm to each other for the first
few minutes. But then, when Yu-Sau gets tired,
Mo slams him to the street where Yu-Sau is almost
hit by a vehicle. Following that, they get a hold
of bamboo sticks and fight using them. Eventually,
the bamboos also break, and they fist fight again.
Suddenly, Mo ends up under a car that drags
him a little further. It is enough to make
him go unconscious. Taking the opportunity, Yu-Sau
drags him to the other side of the road.
He is about to kill Mo but detective Luk arrives
at the right time and shoots him dead. In the end,
Mo is taken to the hospital. Three months after
the incident, he is in prison again. Detective
Luk comes for a visit and informs him that he
is being bailed shortly. In the last scene,
we see Mo and Sinn Ying taking pictures with the
students from their school of martial arts.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification,
and leave a like to help the channel
out. Thank You for watching.